Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
[ GASPS ]
I LIVED IN
MY FRIEND'S CLOSET.
CLOSET?
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
HOLY CRAP!
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
BEING IN VEGAS.
ROLLING THE DICE.
AAH!
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
I'M GIVING YOU
YOUR FULL PRICE.
ARE YOU
OUT OF YOUR MIND?!
YEAH.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING YOU'RE GONNA SAY
IS GONNA CHANGE THE OUTCOME
FOR ME ANYWAY.
WELL, UNLESS YOU'RE A MIND
READER, LET ME TELL YOU.
DANG.
THIS IS NOT HOW IT WORKS!
[ CORK POPS ]
OH!
WHOO!
Narrator: AND TONIGHT,
WE CELEBRATE "SHARK TANK"'S
100th EPISODE
WITH A LOOK BACK
AT THE SHARKS' FAVORITE MEMORIES
AND THEIR INSIGHT
INTO "SHARK TANK"'S IMPACT.
WE'VE ALL BEEN HERE
FOR YEARS NOW.
WHY ARE YOU STILL HERE?
WE'RE THE NEW-AGE
LEMONADE STAND.
BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR
IS THE ULTIMATE EQUALIZER.
EVERYBODY HAS A SHOT.
HALLELUJAH.
GIVE US CHAMPAGNE,
KEVIN.
100 EPISODES!
YEAH.
[ ALL CHEER ]
HEY, HEY!
CHEERS.
Narrator: FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT TO DEFEND
AGAINST MOTHER NATURE.
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JOHN D. SMITH,
AND I'M FROM ORLANDO, FLORIDA.
I'M THE CREATOR
OF STORM STOPPERS.
I'M SEEKING $100,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT HURRICANES.
THEY'RE A LOT
LIKE YOUR IN-LAWS.
THEY GIVE YOU
LITTLE TIME TO PREPARE,
AND THEY CAN LEAVE
YOUR HOUSE A MESS.
[ ALARM BLARES ]
Man:
ATTENTION! HURRICANE O'LEARY
IS APPROACHING THE U.S.
[ GREINER AND CORCORAN LAUGH ]
HOMEOWNERS NEED TO PREPARE.
HURRICANE O'LEARY'S
APPROACHING.
BARBARA, HELP ME
PROTECT THE HOME.
NO PROBLEM.
THIS IS FACED BY MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD
EVERY TIME
THERE'S A HURRICANE.
EVERYONE GRABS PLYWOOD.
IT'S HEAVY, IT TAKES TWO PEOPLE,
AND IT LOOKS TERRIBLE.
[ Straining ]
ALL RIGHT. [ GRUNTS ]
COME ON, BARBARA.
THERE'S SOME
WING NUTS HERE.
THAT BOARD WOULD NOT STOP
HURRICANE O'LEARY.
JOHN, HURRY UP AND FINISH.
THE HURRICANE'S COMING.
YES.
O'LEARY'S COMING
TO YOUR HOUSE. HURRY.
SO, LET ME SHOW YOU
STORM STOPPERS.
YOU LINE IT UP,
AND YOU LOCK THE FIRST FASTENER.
AND THEN ALL YOU DO
IS GRAB THE MALLET.
TWO TAPS.
THERE YOU GO.
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ CLEARS THROAT ]
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, BARBARA.
I'M GOOD AT THIS.
[ LIGHT APPLAUSE ]
GREAT JOB, BARBARA.
SO, AS YOU CAN SEE,
STORM STOPPERS IS MUCH EASIER
TO USE VERSUS PLYWOOD.
HOW DOES IT HOLD UP
IN A HURRICANE-SIMULATION TEST?
SO, YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PLYWOOD.
THE 2x4 GOES RIGHT THROUGH.
NOW, WITH STORM STOPPERS...
WOW.
Corcoran and Greiner:
2x4 BOUNCES RIGHT OFF AND
PROTECTS THE GLASS BEHIND IT.
THAT'S AMAZING.
WOW.
YEAH, IT IS AMAZING.
VERY IMPRESSIVE, JOHN.
WHAT DID YOU USE
TO ATTACH THAT?
IT'S FASTENED WITH A PRODUCT
MADE BY 3M CALLED "DUAL LOCK."
IT WOULD PROBABLY HELP
IF I SHOWED YOU A SAMPLE.
COULD YOU YOU?
YEAH. YEAH.
THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
WE JUST NEED A SAMPLE
TO CONNECT HERE.
I ALSO WANTED TO SHOW YOU
HOW EASY IT IS TO CUT.
YOU HAVE CUT IT?
YES.
WELL, YEAH, YOU GOT TO --
YOU GOT TO FIT THE WINDOW.
BUT IT DOESN'T COME
IN STANDARD SIZES
FOR CERTAIN SIZE WINDOWS
AND SO ON?
NO, WE HAVE
TWO SIZE PANELS.
WE HAVE A 76" BY 85",
AND WE HAVE A 65" BY 108".
JOHN,
HOW DO I TAKE IT OFF?
WELL, THERE'S TWO WAYS
YOU CAN TAKE IT OFF.
USE THE HANDLE AS ONE, BUT
OTHER WAY I HAVE TO SHOW YOU --
EVERYONE ELSE
BOLTS THEIR PRODUCT ON,
SO IF THERE'S A FIRE,
YOU CAN'T DO THIS.
WHERE DID HE GO?
[ GASPS ]
PUSH HARD, AND REMOVE IT.
NOW, WE SELL STORM STOPPERS
AS A KIT.
IT'S A PANEL,
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF FASTENERS.
WHAT'S THE PRICE ON THAT PANEL
YOU'RE HOLDING THERE, JOHN?
UH, THIS IS
ABOUT 12 SQUARE FEET.
THIS KIT WOULD BE AROUND $85.
SO, THIS ISN'T CHEAP.
JOHN, WHAT ABOUT PLYWOOD?
WHAT DOES THAT --
PLY--
YOU KNOW, THE TYPICAL RETAIL
FOR A HOUSE WITH PLYWOOD'S $500.
HOUSE WITH STORM STOPPERS --
$2,500.
SO, FIVE TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
OUR CUSTOMERS TELL US
THEY'D RATHER
SPEND $2,500 ONCE
THAN $500 MANY TIMES.
NO, I-I GET IT, JOHN, BUT I'M --
I'M TRYING --
I'M LOOKING AT
THE OPPORTUNITY
FROM IN TERMS OF WHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO MAKE THIS A STANDARD
INSTEAD PLYWOOD,
WHICH HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR DECADES.
SO, WHY DON'T YOU TELL US
WHAT YOU'RE SELLING
BECAUSE FOR $1 MILLION,
I WANT KNOW THAT THIS THING'S
WORKING OUT IN THE MARKET.
SO, THIS IS
MY 10th YEAR IN BUSINESS.
WE'VE DONE A LITTLE OVER
$5√ MILLION IN SALES
TO 5,500 CUSTOMERS.
'05 AND '06,
WE DID $1.6 MILLION.
WHAT ABOUT
THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
LAST 12 MONTHS,
I'VE DONE $200,000.
MM.
WAIT, WAIT.
SO YOU'VE SEEN
A DROP-OFF?
WELL, OUR PRODUCT IS TIED
TO THE ECONOMY AND THE WEATHER.
IT'S LIKE SELLING UMBRELLAS.
YOU GOT TO HAVE RAIN
TO SELL AN UMBRELLA.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A FEAR.
YEAH, BUT JOHN --
I'D UNDERSTAND IF, IN A BAD YEAR
WITH LESS HURRICANES, YOU
GO DOWN TO $800,000 OR $700,000,
BUT $200,000 IS SO SMALL
RELATIVE TO WHERE YOU WERE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I REALLY
HATE ABOUT THIS BUSINESS.
NOTHING STOPS ME, MR. WONDERFUL,
FROM DOING THIS MYSELF.
IF I WANTED TO, I COULD
SIMPLY GO BUY THESE SHEETS,
ATTACH THE VELCRO --
THIS IS FOR SALE TO ANYBODY.
NOTHING
PROPRIETARY THERE.
TO YOUR THING, THERE'S NO --
NOTHING PROPRIETARY.
I LIKE COCA-COLA.
DO I BUY IT BECAUSE
THERE'S MAYBE A PATENT
IN THE COKE VAULT?
NO, I BUY IT
'CAUSE I LIKE THE TASTE,
I LIKE THE WAY
IT MAKES ME FEEL.
SO, YOU STILL
BELIEVE IN IT?
ABSOLUTELY. AND OUR CUSTOMERS
BELIEVE IN IT, TOO.
LET ME TELL YOU ONE THING.
O'Leary: JOHN --
I-I JUST SEE SO MANY CHALLENGES
WITH THIS PROPOSITION.
UM, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU ONE REASON.
IT'S A HUGE REASON.
IT'S SAFETY.
I-I GOT THE DEMO.
I GOT THE DEMO.
BUT, NO, NO,
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS.
I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING YOU'RE GONNA SAY
IS GONNA CHANGE THE OUTCOME
FOR ME, ANYWAY.
WELL, UNLESS YOU'RE
A MIND READER, LET ME TELL YOU.
WHOA.
DANG. THAT'S NOT
THE WAY TO SELL.
ALL RIGHT,
THE SALES ARE HORRIFIC.
SO, LOOK, YOU SHOWED ME
A REALLY INTERESTING TECHNOLOGY
THAT WORKS,
BUT NOT A GOOD INVESTMENT.
I'M OUT.
I TOTALLY BELIEVE
YOUR PRODUCT IS GOOD.
I THINK THE IDEA
THAT YOU COULD ESCAPE IN A FIRE
IS A GREAT ASSET,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
A HUGE SUPPLY OF THIS READY
FOR WHEN THE CONSUMER
NEEDS IT RIGHT AWAY,
SO YOU HAVE TO STOCK UP
AND LAY OUT A LOT OF CASH,
HOPING YOU'RE GONNA GET
A HURRICANE SOON.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A LOT OF CASH OUTLAY
AND NOT KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE GONNA SELL IT.
SO, IT'S A ROUGH BUSINESS,
SO I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
MARK?
JOHN, YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
AN EXPERT
IN RESIDENTIAL-HURRICANE
SAFETY AND PROTECTION,
BUT YOUR INTERPERSONAL SKILLS
AND YOUR SALE SKILLS ARE AWFUL.
IF YOU CHALLENGE KEVIN
WHEN BASICALLY
YOUR BUSINESS LIFE
IS ON THE LINE,
AND YOU'RE ASKING HIM
IF HE'S A MIND READER,
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHEN
YOU GET FLUSTERED IN A SITUATION
WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO SELL
A HOMEOWNER OR A BUILDER.
I DON'T TRUST YOU
IN TERMS OF YOUR SALES ABILITY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO, LORI?
Greiner:
WELL, LET ME TELL YOU --
I THINK THAT IT'S
A REALLY SMART PRODUCT.
THANK YOU.
BUT, FOR ME,
I'M VERY CONCERNED
WITH HOW YOUR SALES
JUST COMPLETELY DROPPED.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
WOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, JOHN.
I'M WITH YOU, LORI. I THOUGHT
IT WAS A GREAT PRODUCT.
A REALLY SMART PRODUCT.
IT HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE PRODUCT.
IF I HAD ONE THING
TO DO OVER AGAIN,
I WOULD HAVE
LEFT THE TABLE OUT.
I'M JEN.
AND I'M JEFF.
AND WE'RE BROTHER AND SISTER
FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
REALLY?
SINCE WE WERE KIDS,
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
A BUSINESS TOGETHER.
WE WOULD SELL TOYS
IN THE STREET,
EVEN POPCORN
IN THE STREET.
THEN AS WE KIND OF GREW UP
INTO HIGH SCHOOL,
WE BECAME BEST FRIENDS
AND HAVE SINCE BEEN INSEPARABLE.
JEFF, TRY THIS.
ONE DAY, JEFF WAS HELPING ME
MOVE APARTMENTS,
AND WE HAD NOTHING TO EAT
BUT WERE STARVING.
SO, I HAD A FEW INGREDIENTS
FROM A HEALTH-FOODS STORE.
WE STARTED MAKING IT,
AND IT WAS AMAZING.
SO GOOD.
WE KNEW WE WERE
ONTO SOMETHING BIG.
THAT'S WHEN THE IDEA OF OUR
COMPANY POPPED INTO OUR MINDS.
WE SHOULD TRY THAT.
YEAH, WE SHOULD.
Jen: OUR PRODUCT IS A SPIN
ON SOMETHING
THAT EVERYONE'S HAD
FOREVER,
BUT WE'VE MANAGED TO MAKE IT NEW
AND EXCITING AGAIN.
IT'S HEALTHY, GLUTEN-FREE,
VEGAN, AND COMPLETELY DELICIOUS.
STARTING A BUSINESS IN NEW YORK
ISN'T ALWAYS THE EASIEST.
WE'RE WORKING FULL-TIME AT
IT AND BARELY MAKING ENDS MEET.
Jeff: WE NEED
AN INVESTMENT FROM A SHARK
TO REALLY GET TO
THE NEXT LEVEL.
WE HAVE A GREAT PRODUCT.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THE MANUFACTURING
OR THE DISTRIBUTION
TO GET IT OUT THERE.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'VE TAKEN
OUR LITTLE FAMILY COMPANY
AS FAR AS WE CAN
ON OUR OWN,
AND WE'VE LITERALLY GIVEN UP
EVERYTHING TO TAKE IT THIS FAR.
WE JUST REALLY HOPE
THAT ONE OF THE SHARKS LOVES IT
AS MUCH AS WE DO
BECAUSE IT'S EVERYTHING TO US.
HI, SHARKS, I'M JEN,
AND THIS MY BIG BROTHER, JEFF.
WE'RE FROM
BROOKLYN, NEW YORK,
AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR $200,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY,
PIPSNACKS.
JEN AND I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
ENTREPRENEURS.
AS KIDS,
INSTEAD OF LEMONADE,
WE WOULD SELL POPCORN
OUT IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE.
FAST-FORWARD 20 YEARS,
AND WE'RE ALL STILL MUNCHING ON
THAT SAME POPCORN UNTIL NOW.
I WAS WORKING AT
A HEALTH-FOODS STORE,
AND I NEVER THOUGHT
THAT POPCORN COULD GET BETTER,
BUT A FARMER INTRODUCED ME
TO THIS SPECIAL VARIETY OF CORN.
I TOOK IT HOME
AND POPPED IT,
AND IT WAS THE MOST AMAZING
POPCORN I'VE EVER HAD.
IT COMPLETELY
ROCKED MY WORLD,
SO I IMMEDIATELY SHARED IT
WITH MY BROTHER.
AND NOT LONG AFTER,
PIPCORN WAS BORN.
PIPCORN'S DELICIOUS,
ALL-NATURAL,
AND YOU GUESS IT -- MINI.
Greiner: OH!
[ LAUGHS ]
EVEN BETTER,
THE SHELLS ARE
MUCH, MUCH, MUCH SMALLER
AND MORE DELICATE.
SO, SAY GOODBYE
TO THOSE THICK, HARD PIECES
THAT GET STUCK
IN YOUR TEETH.
NOW, BEFORE WE GET
TOO FAR ALONG,
LET'S GET TO THE REAL BUSINESS
AND HAND SOME OUT.
AND AS WE ALWAYS SAY...
Both: PIP-PIP HOORAY!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, SHARKS, OUR FLAVORS ARE
SEA SALT, ROSEMARY...
YES.
Herjavec: SEA SALT.
...KETTLE, AND EVERYONE'S
FAVORITE -- WHITE TRUFFLE.
SO, THE TRUFFLE'S ALL-NATURAL
TRUFFLE, THE REAL STUFF.
Jen: HERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
THE ROSEMARY -- WE MAKE
ALL OF OUR ROSEMARY SEA SALT.
IT'S REALLY GREAT.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
SEA SALT'S MY FAVORITE.
I EAT IT
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I LOVE IT.
I LIKE IT.
Cuban: KETTLE'S GOOD.
Jen: THANK YOU.
EVERYTHING'S VEGAN AND
GLUTEN-FREE, ORGANIC, NON-GMO.
REALLY?
YEAH.
AND WE POP IT
IN OLIVE OIL.
CAN I GO TO THE FARMER MYSELF
AND BUY MY OWN KERNELS FROM HIM?
WHAT DO I NEED YOU FOR?
YOU CAN, BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GROWING SO QUICKLY
THAT WE'RE
REALLY CLOSE TO SIGNING
A TOTAL-EXCLUSIVE
FOR POPPING.
SO, WE'VE ACTUALLY GROWN 125%
IN SALES SINCE JANUARY.
IS HE THE ONLY FARMER THAT CAN
GROW THIS SMALL POPCORN?
NO, HE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE,
BUT WE HAVE ABOUT TWO AND HALF
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE TWO AND A HALF YEARS
OF KIND OF LEEWAY,
BUILDING A BRAND,
BUILDING A PRODUCT.
RIGHT, SO,
TELL US ABOUT THE REVENUE.
TELL US ABOUT WHERE YOU SELL.
LAST YEAR,
WE SOLD $200,000 AND...
THAT WAS ONLY
IN ABOUT 40 STORES.
WHAT KIND OF STORES?
WE'RE IN 18 WHOLE FOODS
CURRENTLY.
HOW MUCH DOES IT SELL FOR?
$4.99.
WHAT'S YOUR COST ON IT?
OUR IS A $1.80 AVERAGE.
THE TRUFFLE'S
THE MOST EXPENSIVE.
THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
$1.80'S EXPENSIVE.
IT'S EXPENSIVE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE DOING ALL
THE MANUFACTURING OURSELVES.
SO, TO TAKE IT BACK
A LITTLE BIT,
WE LAUNCHED IN APRIL OF 2012,
AND ONE MONTH INTO THE JOB,
WE CAUGHT
THE ATTENTION OF OPRAH.
WE WERE FEATURED ON HER
"FAVORITE THINGS" IN NOVEMBER.
WOW.
SO WE WERE FORCED
TO REALLY SCALE-UP VERY QUICKLY,
BUT WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH A CO-PACKER
TO OUTSOURCE
99% OF IT,
AND THAT WILL DOUBLE
OUR MARGINS.
WHAT WILL IT COST YOU AFTER
YOU'VE SCALE WITH THE CO-PACKER?
AROUND 92 CENTS,
AVERAGE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN PRICE
BETWEEN THIS BAG
AND A TRADITIONAL POPCORN BAG
BESIDE IT?
IT DEPENDS ON
WHERE YOU'RE BUYING.
IF YOU'RE BUYING STORE BRAND,
IT'S A $1.99.
THIS IS $5,
AND THAT STUFF IS $2.
Herjavec:
SO, JEFF, I LOVE POPCORN.
BESIDES NOT GETTING
STUCK IN YOUR TEETH,
TELL THE VALUE-ADD
OF SMALL POPCORN.
JEN CAN'T EAT POPCORN.
IT KILLS HER STOMACH.
SHE ACTUALLY HAS
A COUPLE DIETARY RESTRICTIONS.
PREVENTS HER
FROM EATING A LOT OF THINGS.
SHE FOUND THIS KERNEL
WORKING AT A HEALTH-FOODS STORE,
AND SHE COULD EAT.
IT'S WAY EASIER TO DIGEST.
IT'S SMALLER, IT'S CUTE,
IT'S ALSO --
THERE ARE SOME HEALTH BENEFITS.
IT'S MUCH HIGHER IN FIBER
THAN ORDINARY POPCORN.
HOW DO WE MAKE MONEY IS WHAT
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE YOU --
SO, ONCE WE GO TO
THE CO-PACKER --
YOU SAID
$200,000 FOR 10%, RIGHT?
YEAH, $2 MILLION VALUE.
THAT'S AN ACCUMULATED VALUE
OF $2 MILLION...
CORRECT.
...AND IT'S POPCORN.
HOW DO I GET MY $200,000 BACK
IF I'M A 10% SHAREHOLDER?
SO, YEAR TO DATE,
WE'VE DONE $150,000 IN SALES.
WE'RE GROWING --
SINCE JANUARY, WE GROWN 124%.
YOU'VE MADE NO MONEY,
RIGHT?
NOT CURRENTLY,
BUT BY THE END OF THE YEAR,
WE'RE PROJECTED
TO MAKE $40,000.
ISN'T AMAZING I KNOW THAT?
WHY DO I KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE WE'RE
A SMALL MANUFACTURER,
AND -- AND THAT'S THE WAY IT IS
IN THE BEGINNING.
BUT YOU THINK THIS IS --
IDEA IS WORTH $2 MILLION?
OH, ABSOLUTELY.
WELL --
OKAY, EXPLAIN WHY.
WE'RE GONNA
FINISH THE YEAR
AT JUST AROUND $440,000
IN SALES,
AND THAT'S IN 65 STORES.
AS SOON AS WE GET
A CO-PACKER --
CUT OUR COSTS
ALMOST MORE THAN HALF --
THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO
REALLY PUSH IT OUT, MAKE MONEY,
AND THEN WE CAN GO TO THE ENTIRE
REGION OF WHOLE FOODS.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE --
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT THE SEED.
OH, MY GOD.
HERE WE GO. HERE WE GO.
WAIT, WAIT -- HEAR ME OUT.
IT'S A BROKEN RECORD.
AND I LOOK AT YOU, AND I SAY,
"IF I HAD $2 MILLION --
"A BAG WITH $2 MILLION IN IT
RIGHT HERE --
"COULD I FIND
A SISTER AND A BROTHER
WHO WOULD COME
AND WORK FOR ME?"
NOW, IF WE LISTENED TO
EVERYONE THAT SAID THAT TO US...
RIGHT.
...WE WOULDN'T BE HERE,
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
AMEN TO THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AND -- AND --
SO, IGNORE HIM.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW RIGHT
NOW THAT I'M PERSON
THAT'S WILLING
OR THE ONLY SHARK --
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL ME
"MR. WONDERFUL" --
THAT TELLS THE TRUTH.
HA!
YOU WILL NOT GET
$200,000 FOR 10%.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY. OKAY.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY SAY.
YOU'RE NOT WORTH
2 MILLION BUCKS.
ARE YOU TAKING A SALARY
FROM THE BUSINESS?
NO.
NEVER.
HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY TODAY
IF YOU'RE NOT TAKING MONEY
OUT OF THE BUSINESS?
LIKE, HOW DO YOU SURVIVE?
PERSONALLY.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU CAN'T EAT
THAT MUCH POPCORN.
WE EAT A LOT OF POPCORN.
I LIVED IN MY FRIEND'S CLOSET
FOR A LONG TIME.
YEAH.
WE JUST WORK ALL THE --
CLOSET?
YEAH, IT WAS LIKE --
IT FIT A BED.
YEAH, IT FIT A BED.
IT WAS NICE.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT WAS A BIG CLOSET.
YOU KNOW WHAT -- LIKE,
IT'S LIKE WE WORK ALL THE TIME,
AND WE KNOW,
LIKE, TO YOUR POINT,
WE KNOW THAT IT IS
WORTH THAT.
WE KNOW THAT IT IS,
AND I'M SURE YOU HEAR THAT
ALL THE TIME, BUT --
TO MY POINT,
I KNOW IT ISN'T.
I THINK IT IS.
NO, IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
AH. I'M OUT.
Herjavec:
ALL RIGHT, HERE'S THE DEAL.
I LOVE THE BELIEF,
LOVE THE POPCORN.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANKS.
REALLY LOVE THE NAME.
BUT YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE VALUATION?
$200,000 FOR 20% --
THAT'S MY OFFER.
CUT IT IN HALF.
HE JUST CUT IT IN HALF.
AND BY THE WAY,
HE'S OVERVALUING THE BUSINESS.
IT'S A LITTLE LOW FOR US
TO BE HONEST.
IS THERE A NUMBER THAT YOU
WOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH?
$200,000 FOR 10%.
THAT'S WHAT WE'D LIKE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU CAME IN
ASKING FOR!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S MY COUNTER.
THIS IS NOT HOW IT WORKS!
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
I MEAN,
WE THINK IT'S LOW.
ARE YOU SAYING "NO"
TO THAT OFFER?
BECAUSE, JUST TO BE CLEAR,
IT'S POPCORN.
I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH
HIS VALUATION FOR THE BUSINESS.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK YOU'RE OVERREACHING.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
YOU GUYS ARE WINNERS.
I CAN SMELL IT A MILE AWAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, YEAH.
WHAT IS THE OFFER?
I'M YOU YOUR FULL PRICE.
WHAT?
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?!
Herjavec: $200,000 FOR 10%?
YEAH, THERE'S ONLY
ONE CONTINGENCY.
YOU TAKE OUT $900
ON A GIVEN WEEK, OKAY?
I GET 10%.
$200,000 FOR 10%.
AND YOU GET DRAW
AS WE GO.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A WAY
I GET MY MONEY BACK OUT,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
I CAN'T FEEL LIKE A FOOL
WORKING MY BUNS OFF FOR YOU
WITH NO COMPENSATION.
RIGHT.
WELL, YOU WON'T
FEEL LIKE A FOOL.
YEAH.
I PROMISE YOU THAT.
COULD WE START THAT DEAL
IN YEAR 1
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE CASH OUT.
NO, YOU'RE NOT
TAKING CASH OUT ANYWAY.
SO YOU DON'T TAKE CASH,
I DON'T TAKE CASH.
YOU KNOW,
I THINK I'M IN A BAD DREAM.
WHENEVER YOU TAKE MONEY OUT,
I START TAKING MONEY OUT.
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING WITH HER,
AND SHE OFFERED YOU
$2 MILLION FOR THIS?
WHAT'S THE MATTER WITH YOU?
WELL, SHE'S ASKING, THOUGH,
FOR MONEY BACK EVERY TIME.
BUT I LIKE TO PUT
ALL THE CARDS ON THE TABLE.
OH, THAT'S AWFUL!
THAT'S HORRIBLE!
THAT --
WHAT'S HORRIBLE?
SHE WANTS HER MONEY BACK?
OKAY, THIS --
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY,
YOU'RE OVERVALUING THE COMPANY,
BUT, YOU GUYS,
IT IS SO CLEAR
THAT YOU'RE GONNA MAKE THIS
A MASSIVE HOME RUN.
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
WE GET PEOPLE IN THE SHARK TANK
THAT I REALLY BELIEVE IN.
YOU GUYS GONNA KILL IT!
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA KILL IT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T NEED THE 100 BUCKS
A WEEK, LIKE BARBARA.
I'M DOING OKAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $200,000 FOR 10%.
WOW.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
BARBARA AND ROBERT HAVE OFFERED
JEFF AND JENNIFER
THE AMOUNT THEY WERE SEEKING --
$200,000 FOR 10%
OF THEIR MINI-POPCORN COMPANY,
PIPSNACKS.
HOWEVER, BARBARA WANTS
10% OF ANY DISTRIBUTIONS
THAT THEY TAKE OUT
OF THE COMPANY.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
ONE THAT'S TAKING MONEY BACK
EACH TIME YOU TAKE MONEY,
AND ONE THAT ISN'T.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WELL -- WELL,
LET ME SUGGEST SOMETHING.
CAN YOU MATCH
ROBERT'S OFFER?
HIS OFFER -- NO.
THE BOTH OF YOU,
YOU'RE IDIOTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
DON'T START.
Greiner: HELP!
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE --
JUST SAY YES OR NO.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
[ CHUCKLING ]
YOU SAY IT.
BARBARA, WE'D LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
SMART PEOPLE.
WE CAME IN HERE,
WE LOVE YOU, ROBERT.
I'M SORRY. WE REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BRING IT IN.
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA LIKE HIM.
WE ALREADY DO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ LAUGHS ]
WOW.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
WE'VE SEEN BARBARA DO
A TON OF FOOD, VERY HIGH-LEVEL.
WE TARGETED BARBARA
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
AND WE'RE SO HAPPY
SHE LIKE IT.
YEAH.
BARBARA, THIS IS GONNA BE
A HEARTBREAK FOR YOU.
NOT AT ALL.
EVERY TIME I EAT POPCORN NOW,
I'M GONNA CRY FOR BARBARA.
I'M GONNA --
[ LAUGHS ]
BARBARA'S NOT SHARING.
OHH!!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH!
YOU KNEW
THAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
Narrator:
IN SEASON 4, SCOTT MARTIN
MADE A DEAL WITH MARK CUBAN
FOR HIS LIVE CHRISTMAS TREE
RENTAL SERVICE,
THE LIVING CHRISTMAS COMPANY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $150,000,
AND I'LL TAKE 40%.
THAT, TO ME,
SOUNDS LIKE A DEAL, MARK.
LET'S DO IT.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE WHAT HE'S UP TO NOW.
MAKING A DEAL ON "SHARK TANK"
HAS BEEN A CHRISTMAS MIRACLE.
THE LIVING CHRISTMAS COMPANY
RENTS LIVING CHRISTMAS TREES
THAT FAMILIES CAN USE
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
MY COMPANY IS AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
CONSCIOUS COMPANY --
NOT JUST TREES AND NATURE,
BUT ALSO THE COMMUNITY
AND THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN IT.
WHAT'S GOING, MAN?
HOW YOU DOING?
HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
SINCE STARTING THIS COMPANY,
HIRING VETERANS HAS BEEN
A MAJOR PART OF WHO WE ARE.
WE'RE WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
TO GET EVEN MORE VETERANS
ON OUR TEAM.
OKAY, GUYS, WE HAVE 200 TREES
TO DELIVER TODAY.
CAN WE DO THAT?
All: YEAH!
WITH MARK'S INVESTMENT,
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND
THE BUSINESS DRAMATICALLY.
BEFORE, WE HAD TO SQUEEZE
OUR TREES ONTO A SMALL PROPERTY.
NOW WE HAVE A 40-ACRE LOT.
WE'VE INSTALLED
HIGH-EFFICIENCY DRIP IRRIGATION,
WHICH MEANS THAT WATER
GOES DIRECTLY TO THE TREE,
AND THERE'S VERY LITTLE WASTE.
AFTER A MAKING A DEAL WITH MARK,
I'VE GROSSED
OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THIS UPCOMING HOLIDAY,
WE'RE PROJECTING SALES OF
$300,000 THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR, WE'RE EXCITED TO BE
WORKING WITH WHOLE FOODS MARKET.
WE'LL HAVE OUR TREES
IN FIVE TEST STORES
IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
THIS IS OUR FIRST
RETAIL OPPORTUNITY,
AND IT'S HUGE FOR OUR COMPANY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW GREAT IT IS
TO BE SCOTTY CLAUS.
I GET TO DO SOMETHING I LOVE,
I GET TO MAKE FAMILIES
INSANELY HAPPY,
I GET TO WORK WITH VETS
EVERY DAY.
I TRULY DO HAVE
ONE OF THE BEST JOBS IN U.S.
All: HAPPY HOLIDAYS!
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
ARE MOTHER-AND-SON ENTREPRENEURS
WITH A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO GET THINGS MOVING.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M BOBBY EDWARDS.
THIS IS MY MOTHER JUDY,
AND WE'RE HERE SEEKING $350,000
FOR A 5% SHARE...
WHOO-HA!
HOO-HA!
...IN OUR SIMPLE PRODUCT
THAT CHANGES LIVES.
SIMPLY PUT,
WE'RE IN THE BUSINESS
TO HELP YOU
DO YOUR BUSINESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW, THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
ARE DOING WRONG
EVERY DAY OF YOUR LIVES,
AND IT'S ADVERSELY AFFECTING
YOUR HEALTH.
OH, THAT BUSINESS.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE AMERICAN TOILET.
YOU KNOW,
THERE'S VERY FEW PEOPLE
THAT REALIZE
THAT THE TOILET
AND THE SITTING POSITION
THAT IT PUTS YOU IN
PLAYS A BIG PART IN A LOT
OF THE COLON ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
SUCH AS CONSTIPATION.
LET ME SHOW YOU WHY.
ANATOMICALLY,
WE HAVE A MUSCLE
CALLED
THE PUBORECTALIS MUSCLE
THAT WRAPS AROUND
THE BASE OF OUR COLON,
FORMING A KINK.
AND WHEN WE'RE
SITTING ON THE TOILET,
THIS KINK
ONLY PARTIALLY RELAXES.
AND ONLY WHEN WE ARE
IN A SQUAT POSITION,
DOES THIS MUSCLE
COMPLETELY RELAX
AND ALLOW US TO HAVE
A COMPLETE AND FULL ELIMINATION
OF OUR WASTE.
SO, WE'VE COME UP WITH
THE PERFECT SOLUTION --
SQUATTY POTTY.
A SIMPLE STOOL
THAT'S BEEN CAREFULLY DESIGNED
THAT ALLOWS THE USER
TO SQUAT IN A HEALTHY POSITION
WHILE STILL ENJOYING
THE COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE...
[ LAUGHS ]
...OF THEIR WESTERN TOILET.
AND WHEN NOT IN USE,
IT STORES NEATLY AWAY.
SO, WITH OUR HARD WORK
AND FAMILY SPIRIT
AND YOUR KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERTISE,
SQUATTY POTTY WILL BE
THE GOOSE THAT LAYS
THE GOLDEN EGG
FOR YOU GUYS
AND US, TOO.
NOW, WHO WANTS TO
CLIMB ON BOARD
AND HELP US
GET AMERICA MOVING?
BOBBY, BUT HOW DO YOU
SQUEEZE OUT A PROFIT?
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
SQUATTY POTTY PROFITS?
YEAH.
WELL, I WANT
TO HEAR ABOUT SALES
BECAUSE YOU VALUE THIS BUSINESS
AT $7 MILLION.
RIGHT.
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT
OF POO-POO.
WE HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS
THREE YEARS.
THE FIRST YEAR
IN BUSINESS,
WE SOLD $1 MILLION
IN SQUATTY POTTY.
COME ON!
THE YEAR AFTER THAT?
THE YEAR AFTER,
WE DID $2.7 MILLION.
YES, I LIKE IT.
AND THIS YEAR ALONE,
WE JUST SOLD $2 MILLION
IN SQUATTY POTTYS
IN THE FIRST
TWO QUARTERS, SO...
HOW DO YOU SELL THEM?
TO WHO?
THEY'RE ALL
AVAILABLE ONLINE.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
A WEBSITE AND AMAZON
THERE'S NO RETAIL?
WE'RE NOT IN RETAIL YET.
HOLY CRAP!
YOU'RE SELLING --
HOLY CRAP, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE'S A CRAPLOAD OF MONEY
IN SQUATTY POTTY.
NO, SERIOUSLY -- YOU'RE SELLING
$2.7 MILLION ONLINE?
Greiner:
I THINK I KNOW WHY.
O'Leary: WHY?
WEREN'T YOU JUST ON "DR. OZ"?
I JUST SAW THIS.
OKAY, SO IN THE FIRST YEAR
WE WERE IN BUSINESS IN 2012,
WE WERE ON "DR. OZ."
YES.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT
THAT $1 MILLION, RIGHT?
AND YOU KNOW
WHAT DR. OZ SAID ABOUT IT?
IT WORKS.
BECAUSE IN TWO THIRDS
OF THE WORLD, PEOPLE SQUAT.
RIGHT. YEP.
IS THERE ANYTHING
TO STOP SOMEONE ELSE
FROM DOING
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
OKAY, SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL PATENTS.
WE HAVE A DESIGN PATENT
ON OUR ECCO,
WHICH IS
OUR NUMBER-ONE SELLER.
WE HAVE, UH, PATENT PENDINGS
ON THIS ADJUSTABLE SQUATTY,
SO AN ADJUSTABLE STOOL
THAT RAISES WITH TOILET HEIGHT.
OH.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR,
AND WHAT'S IT COST YOU TO MAKE?
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS ONE
BECAUSE THIS IS THE ONE
THAT'S ON-MARKET.
IT'S 25 BUCKS.
AND WHAT'S IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
$4.50.
Greiner: WOW.
WOW.
AND WE MAKE THEM
IN THE UNITED STATES.
GREAT MARGINS.
BUT, GUYS, LOOK --
WITH THOSE MARGINS,
YOU GOT TO BE
POOPING CASH, RIGHT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHAT DO YOU NEED
$350,000 FOR?
SO, WE HAVE
SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES.
WE CAN'T FUND THEM ALL.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THING
THAT WE WANT IS FDA COMPLIANCE
AND MEDICAL-REIMBURSEMENT
COVERAGE FOR THIS PRODUCT
AND GETTING THIS
AS A MEDICAL DEVICE.
AND THIS WHERE THIS TAKES THIS
FROM A AS-SEEN-ON-TV,
DIRECT-RESPONSE PRODUCT
TO A REAL, LEGITIMATE
MEDICAL PRODUCT.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE THIS
AS A DIRECT-RESPONSE PRODUCT?
NO. SO WE DO --
NO.
THIS IS THE OTHER ISSUE --
WHY AREN'T WE IN RETAIL?
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW
TO PUT THIS IN RETAIL.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT IT
TO GO INTO RETAIL
WHEN YOU'RE KILLING IT
RIGHT NOW?
WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT TO
BE IN EVERY WALGREENS AND CVS?
Herjavec:
I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH GETTING THIS
INTO RETAIL IS,
I MEAN,
DO PEOPLE FIRST LAUGH?
Corcoran:
[ Chuckling ] YEAH.
WHY CAN'T SOMEBODY
JUST GET A STACK OF BOOKS
AND LIFT THEIR LEGS UP,
I MEAN...
SQUATTY POTTY IS DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE TASK.
IT'S PERFECTLY ANGLED,
THE PERFECT WIDTH.
IT'S LIKE CUTTING A STEAK
WITH A BUTTER KNIFE, RIGHT?
YOU'RE GONNA GET IT,
BUT IT'S NOT GONNA BE AS GOOD.
WE HAVE A CULT FOLLOWING.
I MEAN, IT WAS, YEAH.
PEOPLE LOVE
THEIR SQUATTY POTTYS.
I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU LISTEN TO HOWARD STERN.
HE LOVES
THE SQUATTY POTTY.
ALL DAY.
HE WON'T QUIT TALKING ABOUT
THE SQUATTY POTTY.
WHEN YOU TRY IT,
YOU'LL SEE.
IT CHANGES EVERYTHING.
THIS IS THE FIRST
CRAPPY INVESTMENT I LIKE.
RIGHT.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
SO, LET'S GO BACK
TO THE NUMBERS FOR A SECOND.
ARE WE SAYING FOUR MILL
IN SALES THIS YEAR?
$4 MILLION?
OH, NO. WE'RE -- NO.
NO, WE'RE GONNA --
WE EXPECT $7 MILLION IN 2014.
WHY? BUT WHY? WH-- WH--
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR SALES
COME AT CHRISTMAS.
AT CHRISTMASTIME,
THIS IS A BIG PRODUCT?
REALLY?
43%.
WHAT ARE -- WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
MAKE OFF THE $7 MILLION?
WHAT --
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA MAKE?
WE'RE EXPECTING TO EARN
$1 MILLION TO $1.5 MILLION
IN SALES, UH, UH, THIS YEAR.
SO, WHY --
IF YOU HAVE 80% MARGINS,
WHY AREN'T YOU MAKING MORE MONEY
OFF OF $7 MILLION IN SALES?
THE COST OF AC--
YOU KNOW, GETTING A CUSTOMER --
AND ED--
IT'S AN EDUCATION THING.
OKAY, SO WHAT'S --
WHAT'S YOUR COST PER
CUSTOMER ACQUISITION RIGHT NOW?
WELL, THE --
HOW MUCH ARE YOU SPENDING
ON ADVERTISING AND MARKETING?
FOR THE LAST SIX WEEKS,
WE'VE BEEN ADVERTISING
ON HOWARD STERN.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND,
WE GET $5 -- $4 TO $5 IN SALES.
SO, BOBBY, LET'S SAY
I BUY INTO YOUR $7 MILLION
VISION FOR THIS YEAR IN SALES.
RIGHT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH MY MONEY?
I'M GOING TO INCREASE PRODUCTION
IMMEDIATELY.
OUR SALES ARE INCREASING
SO RAPIDLY AND --
OUR DEMAND
IS AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WE HAVE CASH
IN THE BANK.
THIS IS -- THIS IS --
WE CAN MAKE
A CRAPLOAD OF MONEY HERE
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND HELP PEOPLE...
POOP.
WE'RE A GOOD FAMILY
TO WORK WITH.
BUT WE FEEL LIKE
WE REALLY DO NEED A SHARK.
WE WANT SOMEBODY ON BOARD
THAT WILL ALLOW US --
WHEN WE MAKE THOSE PHONE CALLS,
T-THEY WILL GET ANSWERED.
YOU KNOW, BOB,
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH YOUR DEAL
IS HOW INSIGNIFICANT 5% IS,
AT LEAST FOR ME LOOKING AT IT.
YEAH.
I LIKE THE DEAL.
OKAY.
I'D GIVE YOU
THE $350,000 FOR 10%.
YEAH, SO, THAT'S --
YOU KNOW, THE PROBLEM IS,
ON THE BACK END, IT'S GONNA BE
WORTH SO MUCH MORE.
LOOK, I THINK
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET
A LOT OF VERBAL DIARRHEA
FROM KEVIN.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, LET --
SO, LET ME CLEAR THE THRONE.
OKAY.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE,
ROBERT.
KUDOS TO YOU.
IN A MILLION YEARS,
I NEVER WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
YOU HAVE THOSE KIND OF REVENUES.
I THINK
IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET PEOPLE TO CHANGE
THEIR MINDS ABOUT THINGS.
WE'RE GOING TO THE TOILET
A CERTAIN WAY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU'VE GOT TO CHANGE
THAT PERCEPTION.
I MEAN, YOU'RE DOING IT, BUT
I GOT TO GO WITH MY GUT FEEL.
I JUST -- MY FIRST INSTINCT WAS
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
O'Leary:
I'VE MADE YOU AN OFFER.
I'M OFFERING YOU
$350,000 FOR 10%.
BOBBY, DO YOU HAVE
A COUNTER FOR THAT?
YEAH, $700,000 FOR 10%.
I WOULDN'T
DO THAT DEAL, BOBBY.
OKAY.
I WOULDN'T.
I REALLY LIKE IT,
BUT TO KEVIN'S POINT, TOO,
5%, AS HE WOULD SAY,
IS A "NOTHING-BURGER."
WELL, GIVE US --
WELL, GIVE US AN OFFER, YEAH.
RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND SO, I THINK THAT THIS
COULD DO REALLY WELL ON QVC
AND IN RETAIL,
BUT I THINK RETAILERS IS HARDER.
MM-HMM.
BUT FOR ME TO INVEST,
I FEEL LIKE I WOULD NEED
AT LEAST 10%
TO MAKE IT WORTH MY TIME,
BUT I DON'T WANT
TO GIVE YOU $700,000.
OKAY.
WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO GIVE THEM?
I FEEL --
WELL, I FEEL THAT
THE $350,000 FOR 10% IS RIGHT.
HOW ABOUT
10% FOR $500,000?
OKAY, SO, YOU --
SO, BOBBY, YOUR COUNTER TO LORI
IS 10% FOR $500,000.
THAT'S MY COUNTER TO LORI.
YEAH.
I DON'T ACCEPT THAT.
IF YOUR INTERESTED,
IF YOU REALLY WANT A SHARK...
[ SIGHS ]
...THEN YOU WOULD
ENTERTAIN THAT SERIOUSLY.
WELL, UH, THE --
THE OTHER ISSUE IS THE 10%
AND THE VALUE OF THAT
IN A YEAR OR TWO YEARS.
YOU'RE TALKING OUT OF BOTH SIDES
OF YOUR MOUTH, RIGHT?
OKAY.
SO, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WANTING TO GET VALUE
FOR WHERE YOU SEE
THE COMPANY GOING,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU THINK
IT'S WORTH $7 MILLION.
THEN, YOU TALK ABOUT,
BOY, IF ONLY YOU HAD A SHARK
WHO COULD GET CALLS TAKEN,
WHO CAN HELP YOU GET IN RETAIL.
SO YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
NOT VALUING THAT
BECAUSE IF YOU
TRULY DID VALUE THAT,
YOU WOULD NOT SAY, "LOOK,
WE'RE ALREADY TO $7 MILLION."
YOU WOULD HAVE
A VALUE ASSIGNED TO THAT
THAT COULD TAKE YOU
TO $14 MILLION OR $21 MILLION,
AND YOU WOULDN'T ARGUE
ABOUT 5%.
THAT'S THE PART
THAT DOESN'T JIVE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT YOU
THAT I'M NOT BELIEVING.
OOH.
I'M THE MOST
TRUSTWORTHY PERSON.
NO, I-I TRUST YOUR MOM.
OH, NO.
BUT YOU'RE HOPPING AND WEAVING
A LOT I FEEL,
AND IT'S MAKING ME
MORE NERVOUS AS I LISTEN.
I'M DEFINITELY OUT.
BOBBY GETS
A LITTLE EXCITED.
I GET EXCITED.
HE VERY IS --
HE'S VERY TRUSTWORTHY.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M JUST GOING BACK AND FORTH.
UM, I APOLOGIZE
IF I SEEM SCATTERED.
A SHARK CAN'T
GET INTERESTED IN 5%.
I'M NOT DOING IT FOR
LESS THAN 10% AND NEVER WOULD I.
ACTUALLY, WE'RE GONNA
TAKE LORI'S OFFER.
Cuban: THERE YOU GO.
[ HERJAVEC CHUCKLES ]
Greiner: GREAT.
I THINK -- I KNOW
THAT IT HELPS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I DO KNOW THAT.
YEAH, IT DOES.
IT DOES WORK.
I KNOW
THAT THIS REALLY WORKS.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
GOOD JOB.
CONGRATS.
Bobby:
PARTNERING WITH LORI MEANS
THAT WE CAN GET THE MESSAGE OUT
THAT SQUATTING
IS HEALTHIER.
AND JUST AS PEOPLE
SHOULDN'T BE SMOKING,
THEY SHOULDN'T BE
SITTING TO POOP.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A HEALTHIER VERSION OF
ONE OF AMERICA'S FAVORITE FOODS.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M CHEF HEIDI FROM PORTLAND,
OREGON, AND COMPANY IS HEIDI HO.
I AM SEEKING $125,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
I AM HERE BECAUSE HEIDI HO
IS THE FUTURE OF CHEESE.
LET'S BE REAL, SHARKS.
EVERYONE LOVES CHEESE!
THE TRUTH IS
CHEESE IS A PROBLEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S LOADED WITH
SATURATED FAT AND CHOLESTEROL
AND SUPER-HIGH IN SODIUM.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN EATS
33 POUNDS OF CHEESE A YEAR.
THAT'S OVER 11 POUNDS
OF FAT.
EW.
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU
THAT YOU COULD EAT
AS MUCH CHEESE AS YOU WANT
WITHOUT ALL THE PROBLEMS?
THIS IS WHY
I CREATED HEIDI HO.
HOOOO!!
HEIDI HO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
HEIDI HO REMOVES
ALL THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH EATING CHEESE WITH A LINE
OF PLANT-BASED CHEESES
MADE ENTIRELY FROM ORGANIC NUTS,
SEEDS, VEGETABLES,
HERBS, AND SPICES.
THERE IS IN FACT
NO DAIRY IN MY CHEESES.
HOOOO!!
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU MAKE A CHEESE
WITH NO DAIRY?
I DO MAKE A CHEESE
WITH NO DAIRY.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
SOME SAMPLES.
WE'D LOVE TO TRY THEM.
WE'RE EXCITED.
HEIDI HO.
THANK YOU, HEIDI.
OH, WOW.
[ LAUGHS ] HEIDI HO.
MM-HMM. HA HA HA!
THIS IS REALLY GOOD, HEIDI.
WHAT'S THIS ONE?
THE ONE YOU'RE EATING, ROBERT,
IS OUR CHIA CHEESE.
MMM.
IT'S A MIXTURE
OF CHIA SEEDS, CASHEWS,
VEGETABLES,
HERBS, AND SPICES.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU.
WHERE DO YOU SELL THIS?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
IN FOUR REGIONS
OF WHOLE FOODS MARKET.
STARTED IN THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST
AND THEN MOVED INTO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT NINE MONTHS AGO.
I HAVE ALREADY SECURED GROWTH
INTO FIVE MORE REGIONS
WITH THEM,
AND I NEED WORKING CAPITAL
TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE
AGAINST THAT GROWTH.
WE WILL BE IN 400 STORES
BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT CHEESES ARE SO POPULAR
IS THEY GO VERY WELL WITH WINE.
FOR EXAMPLE, A BURGUNDIAN WINE
IS OFTEN TAKEN WITH EPOISSES.
WITH WHAT? POOHS?
Greiner: YES. EPOISSES.
EPOISSES.
WHAT'S EPOISSES?
IT'S A VERY RICH,
FATTY, WONDERFUL CHEESE.
THAT DOES NOT
EMULATE CHEESE FOR ME.
IT'S -- IT'S --
IT'S A SPREAD.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS REALLY
JUST THE BEGINNING.
AM I WRONG?
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
TO DATE,
I'VE SOLD $245,000.
OVER THIS YEAR?
NO, OVER THE PAST 12 MONTHS,
WE'VE DONE $140,000.
WELL, AT LEAST
YOU'RE INCREASING.
HERE'S WHAT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
LIKE, SERIOUSLY, IT'S AMAZING --
THE FLAVOR, THE TEXTURE.
YES.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU BLOWN UP?
'CAUSE WE'RE RIGHT
ON THE EDGE OF BLOWING UP,
AND I WANTED
TO COME TO THE SHARK TANK
BECAUSE THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
GROWING A BUSINESS,
AND I NEED SOME SUPPORT.
BUT CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
YOU CAME UP WITH THE WHOLE IDEA.
ABSOLUTELY.
I GREW UP ON A VERY TRADITIONAL
AMERICAN DIET.
BY THE TIME
THAT I GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL,
I WAS ALMOST 300 POUNDS AND...
WHO IS THAT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
THAT'S ME
JUST GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I KNEW
THAT THERE WAS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING WRONG WITH MY DIET,
THAT THE BULLYING AND THE
RIDICULE THAT I HAD EXPERIENCED
GROWING UP WAS NOT FAIR
BASED ON THINGS THAT I DIDN'T
EVEN REALLY REALIZE
WERE THE REASON
WHY I HAD GAINED SO MUCH WEIGHT.
SO, REALLY,
I WAS INSPIRED TO COOK,
LEARN ABOUT NUTRITION,
TOOK ON A PLANT-BASED DIET,
AND REALLY STARTED TO SEE
THOSE POUNDS COME OFF,
AND MY LIFE HAS COMPLETELY
CHANGED FROM THAT.
NOW, DO YOU THINK
THAT ONLY VEGAN
OR PLANT-BASED-DIET PEOPLE
WILL EAT THIS?
NO, THIS IS
A HUGE CROSSOVER.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT,
HEIDI?
THERE'S PEOPLE
THAT LOVE CHEESE, COVET CHEESE.
I'M A CONCESSIONER
OF THE FROMAGE.
I LOVE CHEESE, TOO,
BUT I JUST GAVE IT UP, RIGHT?
WHY?
JUST BECAUSE
OF CHOLESTEROL.
I LIKED --
I LIKED IT TOO MUCH.
WOULD YOU EAT THIS?
OH, YEAH, I LIKE IT.
I JUST ATE THE ENTIRE THING THAT
YOU GAVE ME AND MORE.
ROBERT'S GOING INTO MORE.
MARK LOVED IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, HEIDI?
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
WHOO!
BECAUSE I LOVE IT
SO MUCH.
YOU WANT $125,000.
I'LL DO IT FOR 30%.
Herjavec: WOW.
WOW.
SAY YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT IS AWESOME.
I'M SERIOUS. I LOVE IT.
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU.
I MAY WANT TO WORK ON PACKAGING
AND DO THINGS TO MAKE IT --
LORI, STOP!
SHE'S GONNA SAY YES.
ABSOLUTELY!
I MEAN, I-I WANT TO HEAR
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER OFFERS.
THAT'S A MISTAKE!
NO!
WHAT IF
THE OFFER GOES AWAY?
JUST TO CLEAR THE DECK,
I COULD NEVER DO THIS DEAL.
I COULD LOSE MY MEMBERSHIP
IN THE CHEVALIERS DU TASTEVIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WOULD BE A DISASTER.
MR. WONDERFUL.
WHICH IS A WINE CLUB,
RIGHT?
SUCH --
SUCH AN HONOR TO MEET YOU.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
HEIDI, YOU GOT AN OFFER!
Greiner: YES!
UM...
"UH" IS
THE WRONG RESPONSE.
HEY, IF YOU WANT TO SIT
AND HEAR THE OTHER OFFERS...
OOH!
...DO IT AT YOUR OWN RISK.
IT'S OKAY. GO AHEAD.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
BEING IN VEGAS.
ROLLING THE DICE.
AAH!
Greiner: YOU WANT $125,000.
I'LL DO IT FOR 30%.
I WANT TO HEAR IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER OFFERS, BUT I --
THAT'S A MISTAKE!
Herjavec: NO!
IF YOU WANT TO SIT
AND HEAR THE OTHER OFFERS...
OOH!
...DO IT AT YOUR OWN RISK.
GO AHEAD. IT'S KIND OF LIKE
BEING IN VEGAS.
ROLLING THE DICE.
AAH!
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M OUT.
ME TOO.
WE HAVE A DEAL!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ SQUEALS ]
OH, HEIDI,
YOU'RE A SMART GIRL.
THAT IS
REALLY GOOD STUFF.
BOY.
HOLY COW.
I LOVE IT.
YOU RUINED MY DIET JUST NOW,
BUT I LOVE IT.
HEY, HEIDI,
I BET YOU THAT OFFER
LOOKED REALLY GOOD
AT THAT POINT.
IT DID IN THE BEGINNING,
TOO. IT DID.
BUT A WHOLE LOT BETTER
AFTERWARDS.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS, HEIDI.
WE NEVER EVEN ASKED HER
WHAT IT SOLD FOR.
BARBARA, WHO CARES
ABOUT THOSE DETAILS?
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU WANT TO KNOW SOMETHING?
IT'S HEIDI HO.
I SERIOUSLY THINK
IT IS SO DELICIOUS.
IT IS REALLY GOOD.
I'LL BUY IT. IT WAS REALLY GOOD.
SO AMAZING THAT I WAS JUST LIKE,
"I'M IN."
BEEP!
[ LAUGHS ]
HOLY BEEP!
[ Laughing ]
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO SAY.
THAT'S ALL.
Narrator: TONIGHT, WE CELEBRATE
"SHARK TANK"'S 100th EPISODE.
WOW.
CAN YOU GUYS BELIEVE IT?
100 EPISODES.
IT'S AMAZING.
O'Leary:
STOP THE MADNESS.
YOU LOOK AT LEAST 10 YEARS OLDER
I THINK, ROBERT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE?
WHY ARE YOU
INTERVIEWING US?
YEAH, WHAT'S THIS ABOUT?
WELL, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT,
I'LL START THE INTERVIEW.
WHAT WAS YOUR
FAVORITE PITCH EVER?
THE GUY WITH THE BLUETOOTH
IN HIS EAR.
WHAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
IS AN IMPLANTABLE
BLUETOOTH TECHNOLOGY.
HERE IS
THE SURGERY LOCATION.
THE SURGERY LOCATION?
THIS IS SURGERY.
YOU WOULD BE UNDER ANESTHESIA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I LIKE THE VOMIT ONE WHERE
THEY PUT THE VOMIT IN THE DOLL,
AND IT CAME OUT IN THE BAG.
JUST IMAGINE FOR A MINUTE
YOU'RE DRIVING DOWN THE STREET
WITH YOUR BEAUTIFUL,
LITTLE CHILD HERE.
THEN, OUT OF NOWHERE...
[ ALL GROANING ]
OH, GOD!
AND WHAT ABOUT
THE WAKE 'N' BACON?
THE WORLD'S FIRST ALARM CLOCK
THAT ACTUALLY WAKES YOU UP
WITH BACON.
[ LAUGHS ]
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
IT HEATS UP THE BACON.
YOU CAN THEN ACTUALLY
JUST ROLL OVER IN BED
AND EAT THE BACON YOURSELF.
YOU CAN COOK THE BACON
AND THEN EAT IT?
THAT'S RIGHT.
SHUT UP!
I'M SERIOUS.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU KNOW, THE ONES
WHO I'LL REMEMBER
ARE THE GREAT CHARACTERS.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THERE ARE NO WIRES ATTACHED.
DOO-DOO-DOO-DOO-DOO
NOTHING UP MY SLEEVES,
NOTHING IN MY BEARD.
CAN I GET A "WHOOP"?
WHOOP!
I LOVE YOU.
WHAT DO YOU DO
WHEN YOU LOSE A SOCK?
DO YOU
SCREAM BLOODY MURDER?
DO YOU KICK
THE WASHER/DRYER?
WELL, I HAVE A SOLUTION --
THROX.
THREE SOCKS.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
[ HIP HOP PLAYING ]
♪ I'D INVEST IF I WERE YOU ♪
♪ AND I WANT TO DRAW
A CAT FOR YOU ♪
♪ BREAD IT, MIX IT,
SHAKE IT, STIR IT ♪
NOW THAT'S
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT!!
OY VEY.
OY VEY BIG-TIME.
TECHNOLOGY HARNESSES
THE SPIN OF THE EARTH.
THE WATER VAPOR IS DELIVERED
TO A VORTEX CHAMBER.
THE WASTE PRODUCT IS GOLD.
GOLD?
GOLD.
G-O-L-D?
G-O-L-D.
HOW LONG ARE YOU
VISITING EARTH?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, I HAVE TO ADMIT,
THERE WERE SOME MOMENTS
I WANTED TO CRY WATCHING
YOU GUYS DO SOME DEALS.
YOU'VE KILLED
SO MUCH MONEY.
100 EPISODES AND
300 ROYALTY OFFERS FROM KEVIN.
I SMELL A ROYALTY DEAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: OH, MY GOD.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
$100,000.
YOU'RE GONNA PAY ME 10%.
I'M GOING TO GO TO A 4% ON TOP
OF THE UNIVERSITY PATENT.
I WANT A 15% ROYALTY.
A 7% ROYALTY.
10% ROYALTY.
A $3 ROYALTY PER UNIT BECAUSE
YOU CAN AFFORD TO GIVE ME THAT.
AFTER I GET BACK FOUR TIMES
MY MONEY -- POOF -- I DISAPPEAR.
I WANT A ROYALTY.
THAT' ON THE TABLE, GREAT.
ANYONE ELSE?
Greiner: WELL, ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS ABOUT THE SHOW
IS THAT WE'VE CREATED
SO MANY JOBS IN AMERICA.
VERY HEARTWARMING.
YOU KNOW LORI?
I'LL TELL YOU,
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE ABSOLUTE CRAP
AND TURN IT INTO GOLD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE MADE THE MOST MONEY
OFF THE STUPIDEST THINGS.
IT'S TRUE.
SIMPLY HANG YOUR READING GLASSES
OR YOUR SUNGLASSES.
BAM! CHECK IT OUT.
I CAN BEND OVER ALL I WANT,
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
SIMPLY, CUT THE PATCH TO SIZE
AND APPLY WITH HEAT
FROM A HAIR-DRIER
FOR 30 TO 60 SECONDS.
THE BUILT-IN SLOT IS DESIGNED
TO FIT EASILY AROUND
THE SEATBELT CATCH LIKE SO.
Krause:
I TAKE THE SCRUB DADDY.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE
IT'S JUST GONNA ATTACK
RIGHT INTO THAT BURNED-ON MESS,
AND IT'S GONNA CUT
RIGHT THROUGH THAT.
AND THAT CRAP
IS MAKING THEM ALL MILLIONS.
John: YOU KNOW
WHAT I FIND AMAZING?
THOSE KIDS THAT STAND THERE
ON THAT CARPET,
9, 10, 15 YEARS OLD.
I'M 11 YEARS OLD.
I'M YOU IN 30 YEARS.
I'M RYAN,
AND THIS IS BARKLEY,
WHO INSPIRED ME TO START
MY COMPANY, RYAN'S BARKERY.
GOING FROM HENRY'S HUMDINGERS
TO HENRY'S HUMDINGERS LLC.
WE'RE THE INVENTIONEERS.
SIX INVENTORS, AGES 12 TO 18.
MY NAME IS NOAH. I AM THE C.E.O.
OF PAPERBOX PILOTS.
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE SHARK
BY THE WAY?
I LIKE ALL OF YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PEOPLE COME UP TO YOU AND SAY,
"MY 7-YEAR-OLD,
MY 9-YEAR-OLD LOVE THE SHOW,"
AND I LOVE THAT ABOUT IT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW,
IN A SMALL WAY,
WE'RE A SPARK
TO THOSE PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY, BARBARA,
I HAVE TO THANK YOU.
HERE IT COMES.
I'M GOING DOWN THE ESCALATOR
AT L.A.X.,
AND THERE'S
A GUY HOLDING A SIGN.
IT'S NOT MY NAME,
IT SAYS "MR. WONDERFUL."
AND I THINK BACK TO SEASON 1
WHEN YOU GAVE ME THAT NAME,
AND I'M SO PROUD
TO WEAR IT NOW WITH HONOR.
I HAVE NEVER CALLED YOU
"MR. WONDERFUL."
Cuban: BARBARA,
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
STOP SPREADING THAT RUMOR.
I WOULDN'T THROW OUT THE 70%.
THAT LEAVES YOU WITH 30%
'CAUSE YOU GET TO WORK
WITH MR. WONDERFUL -- THAT'S ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY, WE'LL BEEN HERE
FOR YEARS NOW.
WHY ARE YOU STILL HERE?
THIS -- WE'RE
THE NEW-AGE LEMONADE STAND.
IT USED TO BE
WHEN YOU HAD A SON OR DAUGHTER
THAT YOU WANTED TO TEACH
ABOUT BUSINESS,
YOU HAD THEM SET UP A LEMONADE
STAND IN THE FRONT YARD.
NOW YOU WATCH
"SHARK TANK."
IT JUST SENDS THE MESSAGE
THAT THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS ALIVE AND WELL.
I'M HERE BECAUSE
I'M A PRODUCT
OF A SERIES OF MENTORS
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
IT STARTED OUT WITH MY MOTHER.
SHE'S STILL MY MENTOR.
BUT THEN I HAD GREAT PARTNERS
AND GREAT FRIENDS,
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE DO
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS.
AND IN RETURN, IN A GREEDY WAY,
WE SUCCEED, AS WELL.
THE TWO MOST SATISFYING ACTS
IN THE UNIVERSE
IS HAVING KIDS AND RAISING THEM
AND BUILDING A BUSINESS.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT,
IT'S THE SAME THING.
EVERY DAY,
I COME OUT HERE, HONESTLY,
I FEEL DEEPLY HUMBLED
AND HONORED --
NOT JUST TO BE WITH YOU GUYS,
BUT TO BE ON THIS SHOW.
YOU KNOW, A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
STILL DON'T BELIEVE,
EVEN MY FRIENDS,
HOW REAL THE SHOW IS
UNTIL THEY COME
AND WATCH IT.
THEY STILL THINK,
"YOU MUST GET LINES,"
"IS IT REALLY
YOUR OWN MONEY?"
John: YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE SAY,
"WELL, THAT'S NOT REALITY.
YOU WOULDN'T NEGOTIATE
AGAINST FIVE PEOPLE."
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN YOU'RE OUT SHOPPING A DEAL,
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING
WITH 5, 10 PEOPLE.
IT'S JUST IN SEPARATE ROOMS.
NOW WE GET TO SEE
WHO BIDS AGAINST EACH OTHER,
AND WE GET TO
GO AT EACH OTHER.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHETHER
YOU ARE A MOM, A DAD, A KID,
A IMMIGRANT,
YOU WALK ONTO THAT CARPET,
AND BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR
IS THE ULTIMATE EQUALIZER,
AND EVERYBODY HAS A SHOT.
HALLELUJAH.
OH, LOOK AT THIS!
Corcoran: WHAT'S THIS?
HEY. WOW.
WOW.
HEY!
KEVIN, YOU'RE 100.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOW.
LET'S OPEN IT UP.
BIG ENOUGH.
GIVE US CHAMPAGNE,
KEVIN.
100 EPISODES. YEAH.
WELL, WE HAVE TO HAVE
A TOAST, GUYS.
IT'S THE 100th EPISODE
OF "SHARK TANK."
LET'S HAVE ANOTHER 100.
YOU KNOW,
CHAMPAGNE IS A GREAT STORY.
[ CORK POPS ]
PLEASE.
OH!
WHOO!
WHOO-HOO!
THAT'S IT.
ALWAYS TILT THE GLASS WHEN
THE CHAMPAGNE IS BEING POURED.
IT'S HOW YOU RESPECT
THE VINTAGE.
Cuban: IS FROM THE
WHAT SOCIETY -- THE DU TASTEVIN?
DU LE --
CHEVALIERS DU TASTEVIN?
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW THE TOAST IS DONE.
TO OUR 100th EPISODE.
HOLD YOUR PINKY OUT LIKE THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHY NOT?
CHEERS.
All: CHEERS.
TO ANOTHER 100.
HEY, HEY!
Herjavec: CHEERS!